Watching American Horror Story is scary enough…
but how does the cast feel as they bring these
stories to life?
AHS seems to make a permanent impact on its
stars - sometimes for the better, and sometimes
for the worse.
Here's how the show has changed these actors'
lives.
In the early years, Evan Peters was basically
the face of American Horror Story.
He started out playing Tate Langdon in the
first season, and went on to star in seven
more seasons of the creeped-out anthology
show.
It seemed like Peters would always be in the
cast - but that didn't turn out to be the
case.
In 2019, Peters shocked fans with the announcement
that he wouldn't be returning for 1984, the
ninth season of AHS.
"I'm making hard choices…
every day."
Honestly, he probably didn't miss out on much.
"I just needed to get each of you alone with
me."
"Why?"
"So I can kill you!"
Prior to Peters' announcement, the actor revealed
that AHS was taking a toll on his mental health,
telling GQ in 2018:
"I don't like to yell and scream.
I actually hate it.
I think it's disgusting and really awful [...] Horror
Story sort of demanded that of me."
He went on to explain:
"It's just exhausting.
It's really mentally draining, and you don't
want to go to those places ever in your life.
And so you have to go there for the scenes,
and it ends up integrating it somehow into
your life."
Jessica Lange began her stint on American
Horror Story in season one, portraying Constance
Langdon, Tate's malignant mother.
The role ushered in a whole new phase of Lange's
career, winning her a second Primetime Emmy.
She stuck with AHS for three more seasons,
eventually returning for Apocalypse to reprise
her role as Constance.
Honestly, no one plays an intimidating matriarch
quite like her.
"Bundy, Dahmer… they started with small
animals too… until they graduated."
Before getting that career-changing phone
call from Ryan Murphy, Lange was going through
a difficult breakup.
She had just ended a 30-year relationship
with actor and playwright Sam Shepard, and
had no idea what she'd do next.
In 2019, she told GoldDerby:
"Going into that series somehow revitalized
me and made me understand that there was a
whole way of working that I had never done
before [...]. It forced me to work in a way
with complete and total abandon."
The story checks out:
"What is this?
Knotty pine!"
Emma Roberts was tired of being typecast.
She felt like casting directors only saw her
as a "girl next door" type.
So when Ryan Murphy offered her the role of
powerful witch Madison Montgomery, she leapt
at the chance.
"Azazel, we submit to you, body and soul!
The lord of the underworld, we offer you our
obedience and everlasting devotion!"
Playing Madison clearly gave Roberts a new
sense of confidence.
As she told Collider,
"It’s definitely made me a more fearless
actress.
Things I would normally say no to, I’m more
like, 'Bring it on!'"
Her stint on AHS has certainly opened doors
for her, too.
In another interview with Collider, she noted,
"I remember before Madison, I would go up
for parts and they'd be like, 'She's too sweet,'
or 'She's too nice.'
Now, after Madison [...] no one says that."
It's easy to see why.
"I mean, why wait for some phony, happily-ever-after
when you can have your piece now, I say.
What about you Luke?"
Lady Gaga always wanted to break into acting
- long before her music career ever took off.
For proof, look no further than her bit role
on this Sopranos episode.
She put those acting ambitions on the backburner
for a long time - but Ryan Murphy ultimately
helped turn that dream into a reality.
He cast her as the vampiric Countess in American
Horror Story: Hotel.
"I lived in New York many years ago.
I loved roaming the streets, devouring the
pulse of the city.
Electrifying."
As Murphy told Billboard in 2015:
"She has always wanted to be an actress.
She studied it in college, but she was too
terrified to go on auditions."
When Murphy showed her footage of one of her
scenes in AHS, Gaga reportedly began to sob.
Murphy told Billboard:
"I was worried, but she told me later that
it was because she was so happy that somebody
had believed in her."
Gaga's newfound confidence as an actress changed
her entire career.
She went on to star as Ally alongside Bradley
Cooper in the 2018 remake of A Star is Born,
which was nominated for several Academy Awards
and won Best Original Song for "Shallow."
American Horror Story: Freak Show wouldn't
have been complete without Twisty the Clown.
The terrifying character was played by actor
John Carroll Lynch, and it was his first time
ever working on the show.
The character had a rather nasty habit of
sneaking up on innocent people and killing
them.
And the fact that Twisty barely spoke a word
made him all the more frightening.
That proved to be quite an actorly challenge
for Lynch, who had to rely solely on body
language for the performance.
As he told Collider in 2014:
"There are a lot of things that I've never
tried before because the character is silent.
[...] There was the challenge of being told,
'There’s almost no dialogue and we’re
gonna take away half of your face.
Let’s see if you can act in those circumstances.'”
Judging by his nightmare-inducing performance
as Twisty, we'd say he nailed it - and became
a more versatile actor in the process.
In 2018, Cody Fern joined American Horror
Story for Apocalypse.
He memorably played Michael Langdon, otherwise
known as The Antichrist.
To prepare for the part - and get into the
mindset of a ghoulish entity like Michael
- Fern spent lots of time reading up on theology,
psychology, and philosophy.
Michael has been Fern's biggest role to date,
and apparently, Fern still hasn't entirely
moved on from the character.
In June 2019, he told GoldDerby:
People have more [of] an interest in the darker
aspects of life.And I think it’s very much
about trying to understand the darkness within
ourselves."
"I'm a serious actor."
"Heh heh."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.